one two three four well hold on let's
try and do it a little faster okay okay
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
there we go whoo okay close my window
I'm such an idiot hang up here aback God
I'm gonna close my window too so we had
a pretty successful first run with this
but one thing I want to shoot for is
getting these videos just a bit shorter
so David we got to hurry the hell up and
do this quickly you're going to I set a
limit of three sentences of jokes for
this one got it
although you're allowed to write giant
run-on sentences like I did this is the
worst thing for me because I'm the
person who overrides everything in sixth
grade I wrote a 19 page paper when I was
supposed to write a four-page paper
because I felt like it so I hope you
know what torture you're putting me
through yeah okay so I like to ramble in
case you haven't noticed okay so the
first thing about my video so you know
that I ramble okay so the first I'm
supposed to be this oh my god okay so
the first image was suggested in the
comments the last one by pet shop owner
car parentheses vegeto of solar squad
what it's a good name and it's a shot
from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure so the
first thing that really stuck out to me
is the hands his fingers all look the
same length on one hand and on the other
it looks like his hands are his like his
whole hand is backwards his forearm also
appears to have an e in it
I'm incredibly confused as to even
what's happening in this panel and I
can't tell if it's from the confusing
angle or the lack of context but it
appears that the son has punched this
flying man so hard that he contracted
severe arthritis and dropped his
crossbow when all of his limbs twisted
and contorted in horrible ways I have no
words for this this is truly beautiful I
will leave you instead with the words of
my co-worker who I showed this to damn
that's hot
you know what
that that is totally fair and this was a
female co-worker by the way so late so
so guys if you want the ladies to bid it
you be into you assume this pose it'll
work every time just do this grab a
crossbow and just just go for it
our next image is from good ol Frank
Miller and the Dark Knight strikes again
well Frank Miller as you know Frank
Miller has written some great Batman
stories over the years mostly but the
key word here is written Wonder Woman's
hulking man hands look large enough to
strangle Reed Richards although her
three-inch long biceps don't inspire
confidence in her strength but she looks
like she hasn't skipped leg day yet with
thighs that are larger than her head I
wonder if she's doing something
different with her hair since she looks
a little less like the Princess of the
Amazons and more like the King of Pop
where where is her skin it looks like
somebody took an eraser and removed all
the texture from her skin and all that's
left is the absence of anything else in
that space it looks like negative space
her hair is looks like spaghetti with
octopus ink in it which is a real thing
by the way I've had it it's not that
good and sounds appetizing which way is
she's standing if she's standing
straight forward or his her body turned
to the side I can't tell um it's kind of
both ish like this is what happens when
you have no texture in your body the
shadows tell you where your body is
positioned but with an absence of
anything it looks like a doodle Frank
Miller you're better than this this next
one was suggested by Julian 8 or 9 in
which we see we see Superman get really
passionate about whatever is happening
to Lois I wish I had seen the name of
the book and the artist so I could at
least go find it and get a little
context for what is happening here I
don't know where to begin with that face
so I'll just talk about the fact that
his neck is so meaty and muscular that
it's thicker than his entire skull his
face also looks like it's very flat and
doesn't look like wrinkles in his face
so much is just numerous scars
there are two things wrong with this
spectrum first blue Superman's
expression is the most meme worthy
comic-book thing since I'm the goddamn
Batman secondly of course his neck is
way too thick so what I'm saying is that
Superman's head looks like a penis yeah
okay yeah that's fair
now here's one I found while reading
amazing spider-man number 328 it's
around the time Spiderman got the Enigma
force and became the cosmic spider-man
it was penciled by Todd McFarlane who is
usually a great artist but this was one
of his off days because this panel just
looks so packed in and disproportionate
the Hulk appears to have had some kind
of cosmetic work done including two
bricks inserted behind his eyebrows to
accentuate his forehead and distract
from his horribly lopsided jawline he
also coincidentally had a recent
disagreement with graviton that made him
only six feet tall considering how
scrunched down and wide he is
spider-man's using his amazing
stretching ability to talk loudly into
Hulk's shoulder but I'd also like to
note the pose in the lower panel because
it bothers me how often Todd McFarlane
draws spider-man in this same pose
because it seems like he's only capable
of doing this one when he needs to draw
spider-man in midair I'm glad you
mentioned that pose because so what is
he doing
what does that make what does he wanting
to do hit him with his legs and his head
at the same time just bang and also he
must have gone to the thrift store to
get his shirt because clearly it isn't
from the same store where he bought his
inventions
hey how come the Hulk never got clothes
made of like unstable molecules or
something anyway we're getting off topic
what were you talking about I was just
gonna talk about that that's about it I
mean there's not much he can really do
it this one I was kind of hoping you
talked about his like voluptuous round
ass cuz I just couldn't come up with
anything to say about that MJ's just
watching through some binoculars going
that's my man the dad ass Ted spotter
ass okay so this one is one of my
favorite depictions of Frank Castle
coming from Howard Chaykin and Punisher
max number 50 I originally found this
online but it occurred to me that I had
this issue so I thought I'd get a
clearer version of it to show more than
just and David I have a surprise for you
what I censored part of this image just
so we could get a live reaction of the
full version okay alright do you have
facebook open cuz I'm gonna do okay oh
yeah I cuz you notice there's a big
black splotch in the version I sent you
yeah who is the person boy am I glad I
did that because now we can look at this
man's gorgeous visages he stares upward
with hope at the nearest chandelier
wishing he too could attempt to cut
Frank castles groin and live to tell the
tale I'd also like to mention this man's
horrible scoliosis because his back
appears to curve just below his rib cage
and nowhere else do we have to point out
how much Frank castle looks like Hank
Hill that's right I didn't even mention
it I'll end it all up to you you talk
about it I don't want to talk about it
you know what I'm talking about
hmm first of all is that is the guy in
the blue shirt Frank Castle yeah yeah
where are his eyes what happened
yeah he's jeez squinting it looks less
like he's squinting and more like his
eyes have been sewn shut well I mean how
else is he gonna beat ryuko and also
that guy in the green shirt is I love
how he's feeling up
Frank's leg oh yeah he's getting so
close I could get away from your friends
crotch Mike remember cosplay is not
consent ha ha ha ha nothing cosplaying
is the punish he is the Punisher though
did Comic Con teach you nothing oh yeah
boy I learned a lot about the Punisher
that day also I love how his arm is just
sort of contorting itself so he can get
a sip I was hoping you would have more
to talk about the arm I looked at that
and I just had no idea what angle to
take that neither did I it looks like
it's sort of sneaking out of his sleeve
and going up to his mouth his arm looks
like it's like made of some kind of
fluid and as soon as he's done with that
drink it's just gonna like just really
quickly slurp back into his shoulder oh
my god the Alex Filippenko noise
I want a whole spin-off comic about
whoever that guy is now that's that's it
for this episode we've gotten on all
five images and I think we're do I think
we're doing pretty good on time
considering this is much shorter than
the last one but um I still encourage
anyone in the comments to keep linking
to other comic art you found because
even if it's like a really small cropped
panel if you at least tell me what book
it's from I could probably find a larger
version of it to get more context and
thus make more jokes about it but it's
also time to plug my channel number
subscribe to Davidian productions as
well if you want to see more of me
telling you why I'm better than everyone
else and why I have the best opinions in
the world unfortunately my computer is
conked out right now so you
be seeing new videos for I don't know
how long but go ahead and check out my
library I'm sure you'll find something
that you like and um ah gum the fall
back on whatever the other youtubers say
like comment and subscribe
no no I've done that joke already um ah
why can't you have and we did this last
time there's not gonna be an ending we
don't know how to end these videos um
it's like it's like half improv and I
forget I keep forgetting to write
closing paragraphs like an [ __ ] okay
last-minute morals we need last-minute
more so just have like a weird awkward
public service announcement exactly okay
kids
um duh don't let Dan Slott keep being
terrible okay that's all thing and also
if if if people touch you like that guy
you did in that Frank Castle oh yeah
don't let anyone don't let anybody touch
you where you don't want to be touched
it's your body cuz that's no good